i need you to edit the goddamn interview
no okay he's not bending
also i have sat prep in the morning yeah
i i know bobby here i just
i can give me a minute okay
what the hell enough talk i intend to
remind you of your inherent and
god-given power okay i think we should
all go home
god across the rubicon i'll give you
what you want
provided you best be in a test of
strength
and guilt come from nathan i have 911.
just tell me to press send
someone get my gun out of the glove box
you brought a gun in my car
i'm calling 9-1-1 okay the service is
super spotty here oh you're not
man enough to face me i need a new
combatant
oh yes a classic bout
the pale face versus the dark savage
[ __ ] you just call me
you can't say that oh why not because
you can't there it is
there it is the fire of your ancestors
set it free
set it free oh okay uh
did he just die or pass out i can't tell
but he's looking very pale-faced
oh my god oh my god oh my god whatever
oh my god
[Music]
[Applause]